hey everyone this is Steve lantro with
collider and I am here at our studio at
Tiff at the cinema center at marble with
the filmmakers behind bad boy how are
you guys doing fine great clearly when
you were making this you definitely
thought we are going to Premiere a tiff
this is the this is where we're going
with this indeed
um so I hate starting with the generic
thing but no one watching this yet will
have seen it so how have you been
describing the show to friends and
family okay
um so I'd say it's
um
the best show that you ever saw in your
life right that's that's how we start so
it's a it's a it's a show about
um it's based on the true story of a
stand-up comedian in Israel and this guy
spent his entire life his entire youth
Hood in juvie and the beauty of his
story is that he became a stand-up
comedian in prison
so basically it's a juvie show but
taught but told Through The Eyes of a
Storyteller of a comedian with the
perspective of humor and that's how I
tell it to my friends and family you
yeah well one of the things um for
people that don't realize you created
the uh Euphoria and it lasted for one
season so one of the things I wanted to
talk about with this is did you guys
Envision this like as a one season show
or is this one of these things where
when you pitched it and wanted to get it
made you were thinking this is two years
three years like how did you envision it
no it's almost decision but the crazy
thing is that when we pitch you four in
the first time it was 12 years ago you
know it was hard to make uh it was this
show it was a juvie prison but everyone
felt especially the network that um the
audience is not ready or something but
it stayed with us
um so in a strange way there are many
similarities so the I've seen the first
two two episodes and each episode sort
of ends on a cliffhanger if you will and
and definitely surprising things happen
so how much is it where the whole season
like every episode you want it to end on
a reason to push play for the next
episode
um it pretty much carries this suspense
element
um I think that more than anything we
want the audience to engage obviously
with the characters and you know the
sensibility of the characters and their
relationships but there's always a very
intense dramatic element to each and
every one of the episodes also the
theory the the first season assuming you
get to make more is Eight Episodes how
did you decide on eight was it ever
going to be six was it ever going to be
ten like how did the the number get
figured out yeah you know we changed our
minds like everybody well it was for a
while it was six it was ten it was
everything and part of the thing I think
especially in the world where Hollywood
itself Hollywood is making 600 shows a
year right drama series year you the
drama doesn't worth anything if you're
not taking risks and and and you're bald
and you're Reinventing genres so it's
always I think every episode is a bit
different in a sense that we were trying
to reinvent the genre and we're trying
to
so so the journey itself is when we were
sitting with the guy who's behind a real
story and again it's a stand-up comedian
whose Past come to hunting because he's
becoming famous now and the kids were in
jail with him are knocking on his door
and and he was hiding this fact we were
sitting with him the stories are endless
it can be five seasons like we can write
five seasons before the festival ends
we're so passionate about this story but
we needed to find uh what is the thing
that that we want to start with and and
we're most excited about and you know
how we work in television and in such a
uh an intimate collaboration each of us
would bring what
um he felt the urge to tell for example
I I was really obsessed from the
beginning with the relationship between
a son and a mother on all its forms on
the uh severe Dolan uh films right away
and it was a lot about the mother and
son thing I think Hagar was really
um excited about some other elements it
was so you're building a season you're
building a journey uh that in this case
the first season is is rather a love
story in a sense
not sexually maybe but but a love story
between
him and the one person he's supposed to
kill in order to stay alive but is he
finds himself um as his soul mate as a
Lifeline right
yeah I just figured out what happens in
episode three so without I have not
spoiled anything
um but one of the things though is uh I
thought you did a really good job at
building the tension and uh like having
a realistic depiction of what could
happen because you know to just survive
I mean I've heard so many stories about
prison but I don't know how much is true
or not but I got the feeling that it
felt very realistic to me so can you
sort of talk about directing that
tension and keeping the audience in a
heightened state of you know nervousness
yeah well
I think I have a fetish for for prisons
and it's uh and it's something that I've
been uh
into if I might say not figuratively
speaking but into uh for quite a while
and and I think that you know just
um let's say that just the structure of
what a prison is has tension in it right
so the minute we put uh a very young kid
in such a structure we create tension no
matter what and I think that's part of
the beauty of the show that we uh enter
the point of view of a kid entering the
scariest place known to mankind and I
think that's you know what we wished to
depict more than anything that fear but
at the same time the enjoyment of being
a badass boy and um
and I think that you know I grew up as
being a bad boy and I assume Ron did too
so
um
building the tension through knowing
what it is to be a bad boy you know was
pretty much a
um an easy task let's put it that way
I'm curious how did the series change in
the editing room uh in ways you guys
didn't expect it did
um obviously it's a
it's interesting because we knew from
the start that we want to do across
genre thing you know something that has
real moments something that has very
very hardcore realistic moments violent
moments alongside comic moments and and
I think that what happened in the
editing room is eventually that we found
the the perfect balance for that so you
know obviously things shifted some
things stayed something were removed I
mean it was a really interesting process
because we knew we wanted to do
something that was more than just a
drama or more than just a funny drama or
so I you know it was more it was finding
that tone that very very specific tone
that the show has the other thing though
is you are jumping forward in time and
then back in time in the prison as he's
being a stand-up so talk a little bit
about
um you know how did that possibly change
in the edit was it always scripted the
way it is
um interesting question because it was
something that
um you know as I think that we knew from
the start that we wanted this sort of
structure okay that we wanted to to we
wanted to have a present line with the
guy himself I mean the one who's acting
is the guy that the stories are based
upon and we knew we wanted to have his
stand-up comedy now it's never easy to
intertwine past and present and and I
think that what happened in the editing
room is that we found this very specific
cinematic language to do that in which
it will not be you know just
somebody telling his past story because
we can rely on his comedy because all
his
comedy is based on his childhood and his
very very tough life that he had so we
found a way I think you know to to use
his comedy and his stories to to tell
the present and then you know have the
past with that so I think that's a very
very interesting combination because
it's not just you know a story of a dude
telling his life story talk a little bit
about um because this is based on a real
person where did you feel that you could
you wanted to sort of be honest with
this story like be very realistic and
where did you feel like you could take
Liberties and where was that line in the
in the writing and creation I think that
much like Euphoria by the way when the
idea the original idea started with the
fact that we wanted to do emotional
realism but not specifically realism you
want to find a way to
um to to create something that that the
characters that exist in this world
remember this world and imagine this
world and there are their hopes and
their wishes and and that's a crazy
thing because like when he's telling the
story you can never know if he remembers
it correctly if he's lying if he's
imagining it's a child who is very is
full of imagination explosive
imagination in human more and this is
the way he remembers the trauma of his
childhood so we can never know what
really happened some of the stories are
big on their life and some of the
stories are very hyper realistic so it
jumps with so for us it was
um taking the guy into her tail room in
London out of his uh natural habitat and
taping him for two weeks telling the the
entire story of his of his life and and
his kid who was a chess champion but he
never he didn't really belong in jail he
was obsessed with being a Stringer Bell
type of a guy like dreaming of becoming
a gangster from television because
everyone was thinking is funny and he
wanted to be frightening and not funny
so it was but but he has these stories
about no his father was trying to kill
his mother and you never knew if it's
like his imagination or not right and we
decided to go with it
um
and it's a very it's it's we're still
working with him we haven't even we're
not we're about to shoot next month for
like we're we're still working props
progress it was very important for us to
be here if so we came with very early uh
episodes but we're we're still a guy is
filming next month
oh wow I thought you guys had already
finished the Eight Episodes we're close
additional filming you know how it is oh
no no yeah so so principle is done
you're doing some additional photography
exactly I I completely get it um what is
the plan for release for people who can
to see it like I'm not sure what the
release plan is we don't know it's um we
we didn't go out with it to the market
at all it's uh we have uh we have uh
um a network in Israel and the funny
thing is that when we started playing
with the idea and pitching it we got all
awesome offers to create it in English
and we said we want to First do it in
April we want to do it in Israel the
freedom that you have there to get crazy
to do whatever ever you want from drama
and the freedom that we get there uh was
very exciting so we said no we want to
do it in here but we want to touch and
every place that would touch a juvie
prison like if it's France or if it's
California or Florida it will touch
really different themes and and social
justice issues and whatever and we want
to touch the Israeli because I mean with
12 to 18 you you lock together 12 tiny
12 year old kids with 18 year old
gorillas and and and there's something
crazy yeah and it happens in the US in
Most states as well and there are some
and yeah they're going to going to bed
cuddling and singing songs from Disney
and a moment later they're like turning
like they're violent killing each other
but the thing is
um that you when when you're doing this
it's a Melting Pot where in a beautiful
way they don't really see race or
religious for example it's truly a
Melting Pot they're they're they're not
ruined yet by Society in other aspects
we wanted to touch the Israeli side out
of this and yet doing and an
international show with an international
studio
um so so it's kind of it's it's an
interesting Journey we don't know where
it will lead us but we are happy that we
chose this way to get freedom and not do
it in the executive Hollywood way so it
has a release plan or a TV station in
Israel yes and then it's a question of
what happens with it outside of Israel
so I can I completely understand yeah uh
well first of all when is it going to
air in Israel so I can watch episode
three
winterish oh so later this year yes okay
so it's not that far away not that far
we'll send it over right
I will appreciate that once you've
finished filming episode your additional
photography and you know stuff like that
so
um uh so is the plan are the people who
financed it and made it like incredibly
happy is the plan to start writing
season two like are you thinking about
that or you can't even think about that
at this moment I think they're very
happy but uh thinking of season two huh
yeah no we have some ideas it's it's uh
it's an interesting package because we
have uh support Studio which is now the
biggest and and most prolific studio in
Israel uh and together with uh North
Road the picture turning group in London
and L.A and we have our partners our uh
decades old partners of hot as a network
in Israel we did Euphoria with them and
Teddy production we did Euphoria with
them so it's it's
um it's making us feel at home and yet
very International Hollywood standard
and it's it's fun I'm just gonna say
that
um congratulations for being part of the
Toronto International Film Festival
which is a huge deal for a show
um and uh when you're ready to send me
episodes three and four and the rest I
will watch them uh and I really wish you
guys nothing but the best and um thank
you for coming in thank you